each and every time that you go out
there like it's a lot of emotions that
that you feel like you just have to get
yourself up for each and every game to
go out there and play at a level that
you're playing that it you have to put
you have to go to a certain place before
every game and you like you throw up
before every game and it's crazy because
for some reason like I always hear it or
I'm always around it like I'm just I'm
in the mirror like putting in my towel
like looking at myself trying to get my
game face on and I just hit up and I
just look and like I don't even have to
like look around and like see who it is
like I just know I just know it's Josh
and the way that I like positive
self-talk to myself is okay like and
everybody like they throwing them before
the game but I am ready for this like
I'm gonna go out here and I'm gonna win
this [ __ ] by myself like I got him like
I got everybody this is the positive
self-talk that I have with myself like
to throw before everything because I
used to do it like when I was young I
used to throw before every game but like
no it's like gear like you're 33 and I
always like to do as much as I possibly
can
to really have peace and I know we
talked about this um we talked about
this with with the bills but I'd like to
just have peace before every game and
I'll put myself in a in a mindset where
like no matter what happens even though
I'm expecting to win even though I'm
expecting to go out there and do
something crazy like I'm at peace
whatever happens but to throw up before
every game like that's just what you
have to do before your game and get you
in the right mindset dude like I it's
it's not like a an anxiety like I don't
feel it anywhere else I just get this
weird like gaggy sensation I know it
sounds weird and like I'm a creature of
habit like I'm I'm slightly
superstitious I might not be
superstitious but I'm a little stitches
um it's a quote from the office but
I just every like there's just a trigger
as soon as we get done with our pre-game
I run inside I put my helmet by by my
locker room and it's just like all right
I gotta I gotta get something up yeah
and going back to even in um at Wyoming
college
like I I didn't throw up before games
and like throughout the game I would I
would gag I would dry heave and like I
would throw a ball on my felt like
there's just some weird things that
would happen with my body that I just
didn't feel right
going to my rookie year is either rookie
or second year we were at Detroit Lions
for the preseason game and like I
finally I just like you know what I'm
just gonna try it I threw up in that
game I was like I didn't have any of
those symptoms like it was just like the
weirdest thing so I was like you know
what like I'm just gonna have to start
doing this from now on and
um you know I've got I've got some guys
that usually throw up in in the room
with me sometimes they're there
sometimes they're not everybody exactly
yeah
uh it's like 21 Jump Street right where
they're like everybody going yeah
um no I don't know like it's just and it
doesn't make me feel any yeah like I
don't know it just it's something that I
do and I think it's I try to convince
myself that's like a primal yeah it's
like something Primal like you know
hungry Warrior is gonna fight harder so
like it's my body telling me like all
right get this up so you can go out
there and fight harder so that's the way
I try to phrase it my mind whether
that's true or false who the hell knows
uh but that's what I do right like I
used to throw up a favorite game but
mine was just like bro I it wouldn't
it's a little anxiety not like I was
afraid to like go out there and play
just like bro I want to go out there I
want to go out there and I want to do
something special each and every game
the record for sex for every game like
the record for sex in a single game was
set by Derek Thomas he had seven sacks
in the game and whenever I'm going out
there actually been close no the most
I've had was three and so Derek Thomas
he actually missed the eighth second the
game and the guy threw a touchdown know
and they won the game it was versus
Seattle Seahawks in in Kansas City so
like I used to have like evolved because
I want to go out there and I want to do
something crazy like before each and
every game so it just like when I used
to throw up it just used to put me in
the right mindset so I can I can
honestly feel you know I can honestly
feel you on throwing up a fairy game